we've got a bit of breaking news for you
and that is about the jubilee
celebrations the queen
this is from the palace the queen
greatly enjoyed today's birthday parade
and that fly past but did experience
some discomfort taking into account the
journey and the activity required to
participate in tomorrow's national
service of thanksgiving at some pools
cathedral her majesty with great
reluctance has concluded that she will
not attend so that has just broken that
the queen really enjoyed the parade
today and the fly past however she did
experience some discomfort during the
day and that taking into account she's
gone back to windsor castle taking into
account the fact that it's quite a long
journey and there will be a lot of
walking around tomorrow she won't be
attending the national service of
thanksgiving at saint paul's cathedral
and
the press release says that her majesty
has concluded that she will not attend
with great reluctance however
tonight the queen is looking forward to
participating in the beaking beacon
lighting event at windsor castle i would
like to thank all those who made today
such a memorable occasion so she is
still going to take part in the beacon
lighting event what she's going to do is
be at windsor castle and remotely light
this amazing tree of trees that is up
outside buckingham palace and of course
we will have that live
here on sky news
so that is the latest news the queen
will not be at tomorrow's national
service of thanksgiving at simplest
you